when approaching the architecture of
your data warehouse it's important to
understand the constructs of the
services you'll use
so what are folders projects and data
sets
and how do they come together to support
warehousing fundamentals
like security and cost management on
today's episode of bigquery spotlight
we're talking about the bigquery
resource model and giving you
our top tips for structuring your own
resources
let's get started by talking about how
bigquery fits into the google cloud
resource hierarchy
an organization is the root node of the
google cloud resource model
it represents a company probably the one
you work for
and it's linked to a domain through a
google workspace or cloud identity
account
an organization resource isn't required
to get started with bigquery
but it is recommended with an
organization
resources like bigquery datasets or
tables
can be centrally controlled by
organization administrators
instead of solely being owned by the
employee that creates them
within an organization you create
billing accounts that specify
who actually pays for google cloud
resources
you can also create folders which offer
an additional grouping mechanism for
resources
folders often represent business units
or legal entities within your company
and make it easier to organize and
monitor resource utilization
folders also act as a policy inheritance
point
access roles granted on a folder are
automatically
inherited by all projects and folders
included in that folder
now let's go a little bit deeper within
an organization
or a folder you can create projects
which form the basis for using bigquery
projects are tied to a single billing
account which means that if different
teams need to be built
individually for their bigquery usage
they would need their own
projects and additional billing accounts
would need to be created
at the organization level let's take a
look at how this resource hierarchy is
reflected in the cloud console
where you interact with and analyze your
data in bigquery
in bigquery projects are kind of like
databases in other systems
but here you can have separate projects
for storing and
analyzing your data when opening up the
console
you can see your projects on the left
hand side with the data stored
nested beneath each project name all
storage costs will be billed to the
associated projects here
even with data stored across different
projects you can analyze it together by
joining tables in a single query
at the top of the console you can see
the project where your query will
actually
run all compute costs will be billed to
this project
and its associated billing account
speaking of billing
bigquery offers two different pricing
models
projects with on-demand pricing are
charged for the number of bytes
processed by each query
but with this model there are per
project limitations and quotas
that are important to consider the other
option is flat rate pricing
where customers purchase compute
capacity to handle workloads
with this model reservations can be
assigned at the organization
folder or project levels to handle jobs
within that resource
on-demand pricing is great for getting
started with bigquery
but as your consumption grows flat rate
offers scalable compute with predictable
pricing
great so now back to the resource model
so far we've discussed resources
applicable to all google cloud
deployments
but now we'll focus on resources
specific to bigquery
within a project data sets are used to
house
organize and control access to tables
views routines and machine learning
models
they're similar to schemas in other
systems
when you create a data set you choose a
geographic location
where your data will be stored bigquery
offers a variety of regions
and multi-regions for your data
residency requirements
however you can't query across data that
lives in different locations
so make sure to plan accordingly
data sets also store metadata you can
create descriptions and labels
which can be viewed in the console or
used as tags for monitoring
you can also find details about each one
of your bigquery resources
by querying the information schema
but data sets aren't the only bigquery
resource belonging to projects
other concepts like connections and jobs
can be found here as well
we'll cover more detail on these in the
next few videos
now that you understand the top-level
containers of the bigquery resource
model
let's talk about some common ways users
structure their deployments
first off some bigquery architects
choose to create a common storage
project
that is queried in other compute
projects
in this case a centralized data platform
team can also create pipelines in this
storage project
to actually ingest data from different
sources
you can think of this storage project as
a data lake or a storage repository that
holds a bunch
of raw data then each department can
have their own project for querying the
data
saving results and creating aggregate
views
you can think of these projects as data
marts or a repository
of summarized data collected for
analysis
on a unit within the organization for
example the sales department
this structure is especially useful when
departments want to be individually
billed for their queries
or if queries need to be run in separate
projects
to avoid per-project limitations
another option is to do the reverse
where each department creates
and manages their own storage project to
house their raw data
aggregate tables or transformations of
the raw data
are then stored in a centralized data
warehouse project
where analysts can read and query the
data
this structure allows for project level
access controls against raw data
and offers a simple data access layer
for connecting business intelligence
tools to bigquery
many bigquery administrators use some
combination of these two structures
deciding on your own architecture you
should be asking questions like
how often will analysts be running
queries against these data sets
how should storage and compute be billed
to our different departments
and who should have access to what data
we hope this overview gets you well on
your way to designing your bigquery
architecture
for more guidance on getting started
with bigquery or the bigquery resource
model
check out the links below thanks for
joining us today for bigquery spotlight
watch out for the next episode and
remember stay curious
[Music]
you